we had covid the coronavirus
no no we did it we're not doing that no
we're talking about it but not much
we're gonna
normal show we want a normal show we're
gonna just enjoy ourselves we deserve it
we had what claire had been waiting for
i've been waiting for it
we had chris harrison saying
did you say you think you may have just
met your husband
and we had claire crawley meeting her
husband it doesn't feel like i just met
my husband
this is your the bachelorette season 16
episode 1
premiere recap grab your
glasses it is
time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
oh you guys i am so happy to be
back here to be back here with you to be
back here together
we're in the studio everybody the
bachelorette
is back and it might not be back at the
mansion it's back at the laquinta inn
and spa resort something or other in
palm springs
but we have our show we just had
to get back to the studio to the couch
to the pillows to wine we never left
wine
no we didn't that's nice isn't it i
promise you
single will be no bear no more and what
a premiere
it was
[Music]
right right
right i am happy to say
let's get to it although you know a lot
has happened
and we haven't been in the studio in a
while and it's weird because it's only
me in here
you know uh we're still on zoom with you
okay jc is here hey lauren i'm here too
so is chrissan they're in the ceiling
in the speakers i feel we need to do
something to cleanse the space to start
fresh
[Music]
lauren you can't light candles in there
it's ro it's a rose one we need to do it
it's rose we need
i don't think a rose candle from the
mall is gonna cut it
[Music]
is that a spice you said i couldn't burn
anything
is that time i think you meant to bring
sage
it's time i couldn't i don't know what
sage looks like i don't cook
why time well i thought we'd spend all
this time away time we're gonna
we need a new time time time um no
okay so what do we do what do we do in
the roses and rose world to cleanse the
space
let's really get to it find out the
truth behind all the rumors that
bachelor nation is buzzing about
so everybody wow wow wow we have been
waiting for this season and since we've
been waiting for it
they really gave it to us didn't they
what did you guys think of this episode
i found it to be powerful i found it to
be a game changer
i found it to live up to and even exceed
the expectations
systems are a go to meet player and they
even gave us
a season teaser it just starts like we
would have just taken the episode right
off the bat they were like here's what's
gonna happen
it's a brand new season of the
bachelorette we're not gonna let you
down
because i didn't settle for men like
that
we're here with you so yeah you know 45
seconds in we see claire say that she
definitely feels like she just met her
husband
it doesn't feel like i just met my
husband we've heard the rumors
what i know is that claire did fall for
someone very quickly
i didn't know it was this quickly
but what i did love is i feel like the
show
knows the rumors that are out there and
so they're choosing to lean in
when dale stepped out of the limo it was
like love at first sight
don't drink for everything crazy that
happened in this teaser right off the
bat
the guys are wondering if dale is who
claire thinks he is it's only a matter
of time
before claire realizes the truth that
dale's maybe not who claire thinks she
is
they're saying that maybe the 15 of them
are gonna walk out how about
the 15 of us walk out claire's giving
herself a rose i'd like to applaud
myself and give myself a rose this
evening
bachelorette did we get a new
bachelorette in here
what the just happened all right but
back to the beginning
and by the beginning i mean the end of
regular time yes we're gonna rewind
a bit and they will talk us through what
they did when
and the pandemic happened we were gonna
start filming in just
a couple days but then because of the
pandemic we'd shut down
and you know what did you guys think of
the way they addressed the pandemic i
think they had to address it show the
safety precautions
they took it and it was just enough
because we didn't want too much we want
our show but we are gonna take that
covet-testing journey
um but it's time for the first kova test
don't drink for all the dramatic
reactions the contestants had to getting
tested
eyes watering the thing just got shoved
up my nose oh my god
are we done claire i'm doing this for
you
oh contestants
that words never made more sense
i want to raise my glass of this guy i
don't know his name yet but he got his
negative covent test and he went outside
and he said
what's up what's good world what's going
on
how are you mountains what's up
mountains
what's going on grass what's up grass
gratitude is chic
i love it so you know covent covent cove
and covent covent coven covey gum coven
[Music]
while we were down from the bachelorette
what else did you guys watch what else
were you into let me know in the
comments below
i rewatched a lot of things that i found
to be comforting and joyful the office
my god okay it's happening sex in the
city
but i also got into that emily in paris
it was an easy watch
and i felt like i was traveling because
it was all filmed in paris
i got like really into it
how about halfway through she was like
i'm so big on social media because she
kept taking photos of herself eating
she'd be like
like raw that's not working who ate
carbs for comfort in the quarantine
there's no one here to clean it up i'm
alone
back to reality claire yes welcome
we've gotten here we've gotten to night
one
we are grateful to be coveted free and
they're gonna have
limo entrances
i'm just so ready for this i hope so
because here comes the first limo
we're not at the mansion but i just
raised my glass
to this art department they have really
made it look like our show i mean
look at all these candles cheers to the
candles
so chris harrison and claire have a
little sit down what stuck out to me
is really how emotional claire is in all
this
uh she did lose her dad at a young age
he has famously made this dvd for her
and her fiance to one day watch and
she's never watched it yet have you ever
watched it
i've never seen it never watched it nope
she's been dealing with her mom who's
sick
and then on top of that she's been in
quarantine
put on pause as being the bachelorette
and quarantining alone
but what i loved is she got here
you know and she says that after
everything she's been through she says
i just know that i gotta show up hey
you showed up showed up you always do
good luck my friend thank you when her
and chris harrison hugged each other
and she was about to start meeting the
guys i got goosebumps i got chills did
you
let me know in the comments below hi
claire
my first guy all right so the guys are
arriving and claire and the first guy do
a
deep covet-free breath you want to do a
deep breath together
i would to get ready for this i would
love to and that's great
we had it easy just you know great
energy good vibes jumping through a
poster we need that good energy
somebody came as a knight in shining
armor that's exactly what i've been
looking for
and all i thought to myself was how hot
is it in there
yeah you guys for context they filmed in
palm springs
california in july it was about 1
10. usually so it's hot out here i know
it's hot i know you're hot i'm burning
up
yes really toasty you can see in his itm
thereafter you can see the sweat on his
face and
we applaud him for that oh and then
there's a man in a plastic bubble
i heard your journey was taking place in
a bubble
and i just wanted to come prepared for
you how's the air in there
you know no ventilation i mean does he
have a fan
see all right someone check on him
they're covered free but heat stroke is
real
[Music]
and then and then and
then it's dale dale
dale regale a tale
of dale how are you hi
and everybody everybody
everybody what did you
see of this meeting
with dale it was rather wild
wasn't it dale arrives i'm a hugger so
i've got a big hug for you
i needed this oh we know from the teaser
that we got at the start of the episode
that
claire says about this man that she
thinks she just met her husband
i feel like i just met my husband
oh my gosh so when we get to this moment
in the episode
with the knowledge that claire said that
from the teaser with the awareness that
claire fell for someone early on in the
show
i am hanging on every
single word come on over
and it was weird they meet
dale walks away and claire says
i knew it i knew it
what what what
oh i missed doing this yeah so claire
says
i knew it i knew it and i don't know
what that means claire did admit that
she
looked her guys up when production was
put on pause because of the pandemic
and you know there's also been a lot of
rumors was she talking to someone
during the quarantine stop down time
it raised questions for me i don't know
how did she know what did she know well
we know what she know because she said
it it doesn't feel like i just met my
husband
claire says and i quote i
definitely feel like i just met my
husband
oh my god i'm shaking
oh my god i'm shaking
me too claire what is this she's now on
the verge of
tears is she crying i don't know what's
happening has this ever happened before
i don't know well chris harrison is
gonna come in and tell us
claire and he comes in and he's like
it was happening wow i mean i know his
his looks and he looked like
and clear goes even deeper on this
reaction to dale even bigger she says
everything just went dark and i felt
everything that i haven't felt
ever with dale everything else went dark
around me
i felt everything that i haven't felt
ever okay
what did you think of claire's reaction
to that moment did you believe it did
you feel it was genuine
do you think her and dale were talking
before all this i'm not a big
love at first sight person i think you
can have a connection at first sight and
attraction but
i feel love is much deeper and takes
time
do you agree let me know in the comments
below
now granted claire did not say she loved
dale but she did say that she felt
everything that i haven't felt ever i
felt everything that
i haven't felt ever um how do you know
what you don't know
you know wow but chris harrison answers
the question and we raise our glass to
that
he says that she is the first person
ever
to say something like that on night one
you were the first person
that stood here and said i just found my
husband
setting the stage for what the season's
gonna mean and claire says
and i quote i'm 39
you know these things i know what i want
i know when i feel that feeling i'm 39
like you know these things i know what i
want i know
when i feel that feeling
[Music]
i have questions i don't know what
i'm 39 you know these things means
i don't think that with age comes
psychic abilities
does it oh is it in my future i'm only
32 what's what
will i become psychic that's exciting
you know what i want
i know when i feel that feeling for her
to say i know what i want
that's great i agree at this age you
know what you want but how do you know
that that is dale if you don't know a
dale
whale let me know in the comments below
allegedly she just met this guy you know
there's more to come
i didn't expect her to say on night one
and i quote i mean obviously
i'd love to meet everybody but
man i mean obviously i'd love to meet
everybody
but man what
oh gosh again claire is very emotional
don't drink every time she almost cries
if i get emotional about this but
i woke up this morning just feeling like
sorry and it was just such a good
feeling i know i'm crying about it i
just hope
gosh they really know how much this
means to me but you know as much as the
show is evolving
and leaning in it is also giving us that
bachelor and bachelorette style drama
that we love and again i raised my class
because right away we've got two guys
going at it arguing
this guy whose name i don't yet know i'm
tyler hi
is ready to call a guy whose name i do
know because it's very unique it's
joseph
i know something that nobody else knows
he's ready to call the first guy that is
i'm tyler he's ready to call the second
guy that is joseph
out over him being reckless
on instagram a lot of being reckless
on instagram wow
that's a 20 20 take down if i've ever
heard one
you were being reckless on instagram
tyler came across some information
oh wait they all keep saying his name it
is tyler oh it's tyler oh
i'm tyler hi tyler
big burden to carry the name tyler on
this season of the bachelorette sir
i apologize to you joseph kyle at you
from that yeah
um oh wow and so tyler is already
pulling this guy aside
we don't even have a first impression
rose yet i'm so sorry to interrupt
but something's come up and i really
need to talk to you for one minute
oh don't drink for every time someone is
pulling someone else's side now joseph
has gone to claire
something's been brought to my attention
by tyler
c oh tyler is named tyler c
the pressure big shoes to fill
big and then i don't even know what to
think because as much as i thought
claire and dale maybe talked before all
this claire
then talks to blake and claire says to
blake
thank you for messaging me during
quarantine you were the only guy that
reached out to me
the entire time so she's admitting
that they broke the rules and spoke
before
filming began but claire says something
very important
she says blake is the only guy she spoke
to
before they returned to film that
time you broke the rule meant everything
to me
but even though what blake did meant
everything to claire
it's dale who gets the first impression
rose will you accept this rose
i will accept this road and then she
said
i've been waiting for this i've been
waiting for it
and i wondered for what what does that
mean
tonight like jennifer lopez waiting for
tonight
or waiting to meet dale all of
quarantine
hypothesis that i've come up with
everybody is that
maybe claire didn't talk to dale before
all this but
she said she looked up her guys so you
know when you sort of like
formulate a crush like i'm wondering
was claire looking up the guys looking
at dale
she had all these instagram pictures
available to her
and did she wonder in her head is this
guy it
and so then when she met him there was a
lot behind that meeting you know
i knew it this was wild to me we start
the rose ceremony
and claire says she didn't even get to
talk to
everybody i feel really bad i didn't
have the opportunity to talk to some
guys
in here that i've wanted to talk to and
i feel
awful i mean don't drink for every time
this season has been
unprecedented already but i also don't
know if we've ever heard a lead say they
straight up didn't get to speak to
everyone on night one
like imagine if you've put your whole
life on hold for this
for months months longer than you even
thought you had to
and then you don't get to speak to the
lead on night one
lord but it is rose ceremony time
and even more so than usual we really
really don't know these guys
but you know blake gets a rose blank
points
and she's the guy he talked to and easy
gets a rose
we accept this rose oh yeah and he's got
those easy great energy vibes
and some other guys i don't know get
roses tyler s
brandon sexy oh uh
you know of that drama we don't care
about in comparison to the dale stuff
the yosef guy stays yosa
and oh tyler c does not oh so that was
the rose ceremony we went through it all
and
oh it's daylight you guys
tyler c is leaving in the straight up
full-on
daylight we usually have like the peak
of the morning like the sun
looking over the mountains like just the
spark of the beginning of the day
no no no no yes
it's noon a long
night after a long wait
what did everybody think of the premiere
episode
of season 16 an unprecedented
being of the bachelorette i absolutely
loved it you guys i thought that the
team did such a great job of again
leaning into those rumors
while still making us wonder how they
would all unfold
but most importantly i am so so grateful
to be back with you
to be here in the stu dio
and to be doing another season of roses
and rose
thank you all so much for being here and
thank you jc and chrysanne for sort of
being here
and i am available to you on cameo if
you want a personal message from me
twitter
instagram and the tick tock which has
been kind of you know like a
saving grace in all this i find tick
tock to be very positive app and i like
it
and with that with the dream and the
hope
of escape with the comfort
of a carb i
i will say
bye oh my god you guys
i'm so tired but we've gotta vlog we've
gotta vlog because i forgot to talk
about the teaser at the end
a livo's pulling up chris harrison
standing outside
who's getting out
oh they're not gonna tell us what i mean
tasha question mark
anyway you guys that's what's happening
and i just cannot wait
cannot wait for next week i love you so
much i will see you soon and we will see
who gets out of that limo
hopefully soon bye